hello freak [ __ ] yeah well they're
the best personality predictor of of
politically correct belief because we've
done this study so it's not published
yet is trait agreeableness and
agreeableness I would say the best way
to think about it is that it's the
maternal dimension if that's an
oversimplification but not much of one
and so anybody that and and the maternal
viewpoint is something like anybody
who's part of my in-group is an infant
in trouble and anyone who's outside of
it is a predatory snake or something
like that and so you're seeing that
manifest itself in a political doctrine
well you're clearly seeing that today
with what's going on with these like
like say the Berkeley Milo rally where
people who are on the Left who you would
think of as being Pro woman Pro you know
anti violence are more than capable of
committing violence against women who
support Trump because then they
categorize them as Nazis and we're
supposed to punch Nazis and I mean
there's been a bunch of instances where
you've seen video footage of people
getting pepper sprayed and hit with
sticks because they were wearing the
wrong you know the wearing or uh it
wasn't even a make America great again
hat it was actually a make Bitcoin great
again tap there's a very famous video of
a girl getting pepper sprayed yeah I
think I've seen that one bucking crazy
be and by the left and by people who are
supposed to be you know quote-unquote
progressive and people were supposed to
be Pro women's rights
you know anti violence against women
anti-domestic violence but yet they have
no problem doing it to this other person
because this person becomes the other
because they're on the other side
yeah well this will I was talking about
this line between good and evil yeah it
runs down people's hearts it's well it's
a it's a terrible fault line and it can
be shocking to see that it's the case
and so it's much more convenient for
people to divide the world into the
righteous and and the Damned let's say
and then to to persecute the Damned
right well it's it's convenient to
because you whatever resentment and
hatred and bitterness you have in your
heart and you have plenty of that
generally speaking if your social
justice type because
you regard yourself as oppressed and
then like that's a great starting point
for resentment and hatred right to be to
be a victim we know that that one of the
precursors to genocide and I'm not
saying at all that we're near that state
I'm not saying that but one of the
precursors to genocide in the in a
genocide estate or in a pre genocidal
state is the the acceptance of victim
status by the eventual perpetrators
because the idea is well like we're
innocent we're being persecuted and that
those people are going to get us so
eventually that becomes what will get
them first and it gives you so you have
a target for all your resentment and
your hatred and it's a justifiable moral
target and so all the part of yourself
that you don't recognize as contributing
to whatever problem you think you know
now pollutes the world you can ignore
all that you're on the side of the good
there's no moral effort required and
then you have someone to conveniently
hate and hit and hurt and all the while
you can look at yourself in the mirror
and say I'm I'm on the side of the good
I'm just punching Nazi right right what
is there hitting them with bike locks
you know while you dart out behind a
woman who's conveniently standing in
front of you is there an evolutionary
origin for what we're talking about in
regards to a soldier being able to
commit these horrible atrocities in the
name of war to these people that are
able to look at someone who has a
differing ideology as the other and
attack them is almost like a subhuman
Zira is some sort of an evolutionary
origin for this disassociative sort of
thinking and behavior that some people
seem to I mean it seems like a very
common thing throughout history sure
anything that isn't part of your
dominant hierarchy is a snake it's that
and it actually makes sense from from an
evolutionary perspective I mean first of
all we are tribal primates right and our
optimal group size seems to be something
like 250 we can keep track of about that
many social relationships and that's
that's also a large number that's right
exactly and that's correlated with brain
size right yeah so all right so you
might say well why that
and then you might say well a hierarchy
has to be optimized for two functions
and one is what you want to be able to
climb the damn thing so if it's really
really big the probability that you're
going to climb it is really low and if
it's too small well who cares a few
climate so you wanted us yeah you want
it somewhere that that's big enough to
climb and powerful enough to make the
climb worthwhile and so and so there's
some optimization there now so you might
think of everything within that
hierarchy as explored territory and the
reason for that is that explored
territory is where when you do something
you get what you want so so think about
the conditions under which the limits of
your knowledge manifest themselves I
mean there's all sorts of things you
don't know
emit you know a trillion things but
you're not sitting there like torturing
yourself to death because there's a
trillion things you don't know but then
if you go out in the world and you act
something out and the outcome isn't what
you desired then that registers an error
so let's say you're at a party and you
tell a joke and no one laughs well the
party so you think about what happens to
the space around the party when you tell
the joke the second before you tell the
joke you're in one place and the second
after you tell the joke when there's an
awkward silence and everybody's looking
embarrassed you are no longer in the
same place you've stepped outside the
protective embrace of that particular
hierarchy and you've made yourself an
alien and that's the thing that people
use to process the alien is that is the
snake detector the serpent detector the
dragon detector and it's always been
that way because anything that's outside
the hierarchy is a threat any stranger
any strange idea any any many animal
manifestation any noise any spirit it's
and it's a it's a threat to the
integrity of the dominant hierarchy and
in many many ways so for example it's
deeply rooted because that was your
question
what's the evolutionary basis there's a
great paper published in a journal
called PLoS ONE PLoS ONE about five or
six years ago looking at something
absolutely terrifying
in my estimation which was there's this
there's this I
eeeh that part of what motivates the
authoritarian end of political
conservatism so let's say the right-wing
fascist end is associated not with fear
but with disgust disgust is an entirely
different emotion and so these
researchers did this fascinating study
where they went to a number of different
countries and also looked at states
within the same country looking at the
relationship between the prevalence of
infectious disease and authoritarian
attitudes at the individual level the
higher the infectious disease rate the
more authoritarian the political views
and and the correlation was really high
it wasn't like point one it was 0.7 it's
one of the highest correlations between
two phenomena I've ever seen in the
social sciences and you might say well
why well here's one reason I said that
the strange idea and the stranger and
the pathogen let's say are all the same
thing well it's all because there are
external threats to the structure of the
dominance hierarchy no when they when
the Spaniards came to the new world
ninety-five percent of the natives died
they died from smallpox they died from
measles they died from mumps they died
from chicken pox because you don't know
what the hell is coming at you when you
let something new inside the dominance
hierarchy whether it's an idea or a
disease you know words are a virus I
think that was Laurie know that was a
that heroin addict author burrows arose
yeah that was his phrase Laurie Anderson
made a nice video about that words are a
virus and so we respond to them with the
same circuitry that we used to detect
pathogens now I'll tell you something
even more frightening when we were
working this out because it's associated
with this trait called orderliness which
is actually a good predictor of
right-wing political belief I went back
and looked at Hitler's table talk it's a
book Hitler's table talk and he wrote
that but it was derived from notes that
were taken by his secretaries between
1939 and 1942 when he was eating dinner
and spontaneously expounding on the
structure of reality he was very open
Hitler very creative person but also
extremely orderly and I looked at the
metaphors that he was using to describe
the Jews and the gypsies and all the
other people that he burned and and
destroyed and it was all pathogen it's
all pathogen metaphor the Aryan race is
a body it's a
pure body the blood is pure the Jews are
rats or insects or or lice or disease
and so are the gypsies and everyone else
and they need to be eradicated and
burned out essentially and here's
something even more frightening so when
when Hitler when Hitler first took over
Germany he was kind of a public health
freak and he will also washed his hands
a lot every day and he was also a
worshiper of willpower so he was a
really orderly guy and he started this
public health campaign in Germany and he
put together these vans that would go
around like screening people for
tuberculosis which you know is a
perfectly fine idea then they started a
beautification program of the factories
because even like how messy the
factories were in Germany so he had
people clean them up
you know sweep them out and plant
flowers out front and and fumigate them
with for rats and insects right
parasites oh and the Jews were always
compared to rats and insects as well
they used cycle on B to do the
insecticide well zyklon-b
that was the gas that was used in the in
the death camps so went like pathogen
insect rats then it went into the
asylums you know so that people who were
mentally deficient they were like
parasites and rats and then it was Jews
and Gypsies and parasites and rats and
they were using zyklon-b and non cycle
on a I believe they were using zyklon-b
I don't know I know that the gas was
Zyklon or the icon a was the gas that
was formulated with a very extreme smell
so that people would smell it and know
because it was extremely toxic zyklon-b
it all came from Fritz Haber lumber
where the thing I created the harbor
method of extracting nitrogen from the
oxygen that we use for fertilizer today
Harbor created Zyklon a and made it
extremely toxic smelling so that you
would know to avoid it Zyklon B that
that whatever element was removed from
the scenario so that it would be used in
gas chambers they'd have no idea they're
being gassed right robber who was a Jew
ironically did not know that his Zaycon
a was eventually going to be used on his
own people yeah well I suspect they
probably use I clone a doing a
fumigations you know but but the thing
is
that well so you know you said what's
the biological basis and the biological
basis is that like we're basically wired
in some sense also to for the domain of
order or the domain of chaos that's
another way of thinking about it the
domain of order once again is where you
are when what you're doing is working
because you see because our our
environment isn't just natural it's also
social so not only do you have to deal
with the vagaries of the natural world
properly so that it gives you what
you're aiming at that's how you know if
you're right it gives you what you're
aiming at but you have to do it in a way
that other people approve of and support
that's a very tight constraint we talked
about that as a constraint on the
interpretation of the world but then now
and then something happens to disrupt
that stability so that's like the white
circle that's the black circle in the
white serpent in the in yang symbol you
know how they're colored white one
that's order the white one has a black
dot in it and that's because chaos can
come pouring through into order at any
moment and you have a circuit that
detects that and that's the same circuit
that detects snakes or predators and
obviously why wouldn't it be you know an
intruding force and intruding force has
to be responded to right now right so
there's a need for a demand
instantaneous response continuous it's
almost like you were saying of those
kids like almost a unhuman more a
disassociative sort of the ability to
act almost as if like like something
other than a person with a reason a
logic you man eyes Asia right and the D
human the thing is is another thing
that's so funny is that we think that
the natural response to looking at a
human being is humanization and that
isn't right like the default person in
some sense isn't human
the default member of your tribe is
human I mean most tribes around the
world the name for their tribe is the
people implying that there are the
people and all those other things there
are barbarians right there they're
forces of chaos they're the stranger
they bring disease in trouble now I
don't want to be too bleak about it
because this is the basic debate between
conservatives and liberals to some
degree is the conservatives
the stranger equals pathogen root more
frequently and they're less attracted to
the idea of the free of or they work
conventionally that trade with the
foreigner has benefits that outweigh the
that the risks and generally speaking
liberals have the opposite attitude so
but that's because those two things are
both true one is that man it's really
useful to trade with strangers because
there are all sorts of cool things you
don't have but be well it might be real
dangerous because you don't know what
those things are infected with like
realistically speaking let's say but
then also metaphorically speaking you
know here's an example of how uh how
objects can be a virus think about the
automobile like if you wanted to
introduce something into a communist
country that screamed the paramount
status of the individual you couldn't
possibly create something that broadcast
out more clearly than a car right the
car is driven by one person the person
is completely autonomous they're
completely sealed off they don't need
any state support or sanction whatsoever
to move around in the car it's like if
you wanted to in if you wanted to rescue
the Communists from their collective
pathology the best thing to do would be
to parachute in automobiles because the
automobile just screams individual
autonomy and so when you when you get a
an artifact from a foreigner you don't
know what that's contaminated with let's
put it that way and so we have a circuit
for dealing with that and it's a it's a
it's the thing that associates the
foreigner with the force that eats the
Sun when it sets at night that's the
most archaic way of thinking about it
but it's the snake or the predator hmm
so and what do you do with a snake or a
predator man you burn it you kill it you
crush it it's like there's a there's a
destructive force that comes along with
it with that that's absolutely well it's
morally righteous because yeah you you
know if it's a
a snake and it's threatening the village
obviously you kill it and then you're
celebrated for it so in a sense the same
dehumanizing force that allows people to
act that way in war also allows people
to disassociate between anyone who
doesn't agree with their ideology in a
school setting in the university like
what happened in that's why I don't like
idiot that's why I don't like ideologies
because the ideology desert divides the
world into those safely ensconced within
our dominance hierarchy and serpents and
so that's dangerous and the reason that
this doctrine that I described about the
line between good and evil running down
the individuals heart I mean I got that
particular line mostly from Alexander
Solzhenitsyn but it's also a it's a it's
an idea that's been developed
intensively in the West for thousands
and thousands of years and I mean maybe
it's been developed since far before we
we invented the stories in Genesis
because of course the serpent see in
Genesis of course Genesis is like a
paradise right so you can think about it
as a well-functioning hierarchy it's
also a balance between chaos and order
to God walls and it's a garden so but
there's a snake that pops its head in
and that's the same as that as I said
that black dot inside the white serpent
in the yin-yang symbol it's that no
matter how doesn't matter how perfect
the the environment is set up something
that doesn't fit is going to make its
way inside it's one of the oldest
stories of mankind and you see the thing
that makes its itself manifest inside in
the Genesis story is a snake
now that snake turns out to be Satan
which is like how the hell does that
happen it's a snake like what where does
that come from
it's not actually in the biblical
writings to any degree it's part of the
surrounding mythology well it's partly
because people started to figure out
that the worst snake wasn't a snake the
worst snake was the snake that was
inside a person because a malevolent
person is way more of a threat than just
a snake like a snake wants to bite you
didn't wants to eat you and all of that
and and they were hell on our extremely
primordial ancestors
but the human race has been trying to
figure out where the threat is forever
well first of all it was external right
it was all external it was the snake it
was the Barbarian but then it got
localized to some degree inside the
individuals like that's a bad person
that person has a snake in them and then
the idea kind of came out this is so
cool the idea is that well the snake
that's inside bad person a-and the snake
that's inside bad person B is somehow
the same so that's where the idea of an
articulated morality starts to come from
is there's an equivalence of evil across
individuals so then the idea of evil
itself starts to become abstracted at
the same time that the idea of good does
while evil gets associated with Satan
and Satan gets associated with the snake
it's it's mind-boggling I mean these are
how these he we were chimps for Christ's
sake you know it took us a long time to
develop up say an ideal just to say the
word an ideal implies a counter ideal
say well those things were embodied way
before they were ideas and after they
were embodied first not as bad but as a
bad thing or a bad person bad had to be
extracted out of that and even that was
extracted as a drama first you know it
was like the bad guy in a movie he isn't
a bad guy he's a composite bad guy you
know he's he's a literary bad guy and
the good guy isn't just a good guy he's
a literary good guy he's a hero he's got
way more heroic attributes than the
typical person and that's where abstract
ideas are born so anyways back to your
question II you said you said what's the
evolutionary basis for that sort of
dissociative yeah yeah a view and
dallying yeah so yeah I'm afraid that
was a big rabbit hole man no it's a
great rabbit hole and it makes a whole
lot of sense that there's an actual that
there and I knew you probably knew this
which is why I asked you I knew you had
an answer rather that there is some sort
of an evolutionary basis for that sort
of ability that people have to look at
someone as the other you bet well also
how the hell are you going to respond in
war if you don't have that right you
know like that was always an issue with
people with invading tribes and like you
said with other X
Journal threats whether it was animals
or insects or snakes or anything they
could kill you yeah well I mean in a in
a primordial situation I mean guys are
in warrior mode a good part of the time
and modern people don't even know what
that's like that's why they go out and
they go into warrior mode and they get
post-traumatic stress disorder because
it's so unlike the way they configure
themselves that that they can't even
they can't even bridge the gap between
the two identities
[Applause]
[Music]